something that i discovered too during
my career is
being the strongest man in the world
that's my that was my dream when i was
young that's why i did ufc i wanted to
be the stronger man in the world
and i realized over the years it did not
exist
you cannot be the stronger man in the
world this is an illusion i love the
younger guy this help the baddest man
no you're not man it doesn't exist
you would be strong you would be a
better fighter than this guy
in that particular day at that
particular location at that particular
moment
maybe in an hour if the fight would
occur an hour later an
hour before or maybe in a different
place where they the altitude desire or
lower or the
different scenario different environment
you will lose that fight
it's always a question of words you know
what i mean so being the stronger man in
the world it does it's
style makes fight maybe we're three guys
i beat you you beat him he beat me who's
this who's the best guy
there's no best guy right that's mma
math right
that's the way to see it so there is no
stronger man in the world you can't you
say oh i'm the baddest man on the planet
because i'm champion
like the belting is is an illusion the
belting
the belting is a symbol but it's an
illusion it doesn't exist you're not the
stronger man in the world
i know a lot of people will disagree
with me but is it is what it is that's
if you ask most experienced fighters
most people will think the same way
because we realize at one point like
when we're young because of our
confidence or maybe our the cockiness
or our confidence after it
not that it fades but we we we see we
have more experience
knowledge we realize it's all it's all
bs it's not true so the ufc
offered you nate diaz did you consider
it at all or did was it
like i consider it i consider it